hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com so in this video we are
going to go through amc gme press action
i didn't do gme last
friday sorry about that we're going to
discuss that today
and i'm gonna give you my view for the
global market which of course is gonna
impact the meme stocks especially amc
and gme i mean not especially but also
amc and gme and i'm gonna uh so give you
my view and associate combine this view
with what is happening on the yields
because as you guys know the yields are
correlated with inflation which is
itself correlated with what the market
is doing so let's get into it
all right
we start with amc in my last video i was
telling you guys that we were having
uh what was it an inverted hammer right
as you can see here
an inverted hammer has formed all right
pam pam pam so let's put that in green
it is a bullish
signal right an inverted hammer is a
bullish signal when found at the end of
a downtrend it's not the strongest one
because
we don't close as you see we opened here
and we didn't close above the previous
open we close below so it's not a
pushing elephant it's a hammer so i was
also telling you that whenever you have
a bullish candlestick pattern whatever
it is bullish angle thing morning star
inverted hammer
um
you have more but whatever it is you can
always
basically do the same thing which is
dividing the last candlestick i mean the
whole pattern if you have two candles
you take the biggest one in three
zones all right you remember that and i
was telling you that we have
you know the buying area the bullish
area the neutral area and the bearish
area remember all right and we opened in
the neutral area because we happened
below it was 12.3 if i remember well
uh and we opened below that as you can
see we open at 12.11
we moved a little bit higher and i mean
as the neutral area is suggesting we
stayed in this area we were neutral
basically
none of the camp won the day but for
bulls it's a small victory because we
were clearly bearish strongly bearish we
then had this reversal pattern and we
are now in a neutral area so we are
still neutral for monday
um
and
we can basically keep roughly the same
zones
we can add to that
because we need to understand where is
the resistance level
and let me get rid of the zones because
usually you can use it the next day but
two days after it's not the best
whenever you had a candlestick pattern
here as you can see if i get rid of that
this trendline is still active so i told
you that many times but it's always good
to always good to make some reminders
uh is that whenever
uh a support is broken it becomes
resistance and that's true even for
trend lines that have been you know
declining trend lines downward sloping
trend lines that have been broken on the
downside and then when the price action
wants to get back in it
it's not always acting as resistance but
here we can see it it is right i mean
here not perfectly but here it acted as
resistance so to me this is the area of
resistance so roughly around 12.5 20
12.6
uh and the
major resistance which is the pivot
point we have a pivot point is a
horizontal support or resistance where
you had multiple reactions in the past
and usually a lot of volume so here it
is our pivot point 13.5 so i would say
that on the short term
above 12.5 we are bullish but on the
medium term we need to get above
13.5 so i don't know what's going to
happen next week but i think that we
might have maybe one or two more days of
bullish price action and then
maybe some more bearish
um situations so we're gonna see let me
explain to you why uh so here i don't
have a strong view on amc
uh rather neutral right now on the short
term
uh but bulls are definitely trying to
take back control as you can see we were
here oversold in the rsi we had a
bullish reaction we are now we we now
have uh we are we have here here this
inverted hammer that occurred on
increasing volume one of the biggest
volume we had
i mean the biggest volume we had since
the nice move up we had in march
so clearly there is something up but for
now bull didn't really take back control
on the medium term
[Music]
so let's see what's going to happen here
the next report is still 9
it doesn't look like we're going to go
to 9 on monday or tuesday but if we have
another leg down on the global market
will very likely go to nine
even maybe uh 7.6 all right so just keep
that in mind for now to me we are not
out of trouble uh even if we have some
good signs that we're happy to see that
we didn't see for a while we have
probably citadel
after each tweet that is a bit
i mean probably a trap trying to
manipulate the market you know as they
usually do
but definitely they are buying i think
that they were involved in this uh trade
as you saw guys on the five minutes time
frame we had the biggest volume since a
very very very long time it was here bam
you see on the 500 frame this was
probably citadel buying
this is my guess i'm not sure so but i
don't think it was shots covering i
think it was natural buyers
because the market was going up uh but
whatever
neutral and we need to have more
information
uh to see what's gonna happen
so jimmy it's interesting because those
two move together
but uh they don't give the same signals
and here what is that guys what is this
candlestick pattern i'm sure you know
that it is uh
how is it called sorry i forgot uh
abandoned baby i think no it's not this
one
this is uh the pregnant woman ah let me
find it i forgot the name
harami i think
harami
candlestick pattern
yeah you see it's a harami it's a
bullish harami all right it's this one
guys
okay so harami means pregnant woman in
japanese and this small candle
represents the baby and this is the
woman and this is the belly okay
so
very japanese but it's a bullish
candlestick pattern that is showing it's
a bit the same like the inverted hammer
right it means it shows that bulls are
trying something
uh that bears were in control and they
are no more in control all right then we
can do the same little game
dividing that in three
okay bam bam bam it gives us three areas
and
gme a bit the same thing the option i'm
not doing that very precisely you can do
it guys okay
108.77
so 12
12 get one is enough
okay so 101
okay
roughly
sorry
99 okay so we opened exactly on the um
on the neutral area and we stay a little
bit above but we are really at the limit
so same information basically as from
amc increasing volume
uh bullish candlestick pattern and we
are in the neutral area the major
resistance level is here created by this
trendline to me i said to me because we
didn't have any recent reaction all
right on this this is why i say to me
because this is where i would personally
see a resistance but as long as we don't
have a rejection we are not sure it is
but if we have one rejection and then we
consolidate
as you guys know if we consider just
below the resistance area after multiple
reactions it makes it very clear for
everyone that this is the resistance
area and whatever we're gonna go through
if we have an increase in the volume
it's gonna be a bullish signal used by
algorithms retail traders and many more
so we're gonna probably have a good
distraction
for now we are not there yet bears in
control on the medium term just like for
amc boos are trying to take back control
in the short term they i they
they are in control in the very short
term we can say it
um so yeah major resistance 100 or 510
this is the level to take uh bam bam bam
and as you can see we had a beautiful
reaction at 77 here
uh i didn't buy personally i can explain
why so of course
right now
i mean it was not the good decision but
i still gonna explain why
so that you guys you know remember those
small techniques even if here it didn't
work it's still good to remember
whenever a support has not been touched
for a long time okay like here
and then it's touched then i like to buy
right if especially if i have an
oversold rsi
but here as you can see we came close to
support
and then we came back again to it so the
second time i don't like to buy even if
sometimes we go three four times and
then we have a rebound the first time is
just the safest the second one is
already a bit risky the third and fourth
time are really to be avoided
i mean it's even good to play the other
way around whenever you see a support
resistance has been tested multiple
times in a short time this is this
consolidation period i'm talking about
and this is where you can play the
breakout before it happens so there is a
risk that is higher but there is also a
higher reward so that's something that
is
interesting to do
uh so this is the reason why i didn't
buy 77 if we come back to 77 guys i will
of course not bike because it's going to
be the third time so the third time is
going to be more risky even more
all right now so basically mcgme bullish
reactions bullish signals on the short
term
best in control the medium term but
we're doing a great work we have some
volume coming back we have some buyers
probably hedge funds that come in and
written investors of course that are
coming in the trade um
and so we don't really know what's going
to happen right so this is when we go
and check the global market that is
helping us to understand what is
happening so triple q i can take spy i
can take whatever i like triple q
because i have good
signals
and um
i did a very good
swing trading job since december for
those who are with me in discord you
know that we've made a lot of money on
the way down we made some money on the
way up
and i mean
i'm just used to trade this index and
it's easier for me to make ta here than
on amc or whatever other stock because
the volume are bigger and this is more
civilized market where you cannot have
manipulation at least
not obvious manipulation so it's better
for me to make good predictions
uh so here
the situation is that we have oh again a
candlestick pattern guys
look at that what is it
what is it
this is a morning star guys all right
morningstar
okay it's
this one all right so whenever you have
a move down three candles just like here
and you have a little gap down and then
a little gap up that is showing that
there is volatility here and here
and you have one candle below the two
other ones so you have three candles
forming this pattern this is a
strong bullish pattern
especially if you have volume here
unfortunately you can see the volume is
decreasing on the way up which is not
good but once again on triple q which is
a etf of an index nasdaq 100
uh you often gonna have volume going
lower whenever the market is bullish
because you know investors just trade
more when they are scared on the way
down so i mean it's kind of acceptable
we see the volume decreasing
in this pattern but it's still not very
powerful sometimes you can see we have
the volume growing okay like here
so it didn't give us i mean give us
in the end quite nice move up right
so here i don't see this increasing
volume on the green day so we have a
nice pattern with that volume so we need
to be careful but same as for amc and
jimmy we can see that something is up
that bulls are trying to take back
control so
my take is that we're gonna have maybe a
you know bullish monday tuesday maybe
wednesday and then we're gonna arrive
here okay
in this area around three or five three
ten okay
i will personally
short again
increase my short position i took some
profits already
and i'm gonna add and i still have my
short position i want you to take full
profits
here around 280 i missed it as you can
see
but i'm still going to increase my shot
position because i believe we're going
to move lower and we're going to explain
why
and if i'm wrong i have a stop loss just
above so i don't care i'm just going to
lose a little bit and we're going to be
in a nice move up so i'm going to be
happy with all my stocks so it's a
win-win situation i mean not win-win but
i think it's the right thing to do
um
bam bam bam so i'm gonna take a short
position around this trend line for
those who not financial advice but for
those who want to take a short position
this is the kind of thing that you might
be considering
uh you know
305 to 310 this is the level i'm
personally gonna short i'm gonna send an
alert in discord as usual
uh bam bam bam so here yes here two
scenarios and i'm gonna explain to you
why i'm afraid it's the uh
bad scenario that's gonna happen
so as you can see we've been doing some
elliot wave counting here
in the past week two weeks and i was
telling you already here that a fifth
wave might be on the way right so
this fifth wave in green so maybe we
have completed one two three four five
in green here
okay this c wave because this is only a
c wave abc and i told you guys be
careful b waves are tricky blah blah
blah you remember here we took a short
position this was a typical b wave trap
without volume even if there was
volatility i remember i was doubting a
bit is it a b wave or is it a reversal
you know you never know for sure
but this was a b wave and now we are
doing the c wave so the c wave as you
can see it can go very low okay be
careful c waves are always i mean
usually not always but
exceeding what investors think and they
create
uh panic
capitulation
this kind of events all right because
investors usually buy the div and then
we go over and they sell here they
capitulate which means they take the
loss usually at the worst time and this
is when big money players you know
accumulate
a lot of shares and
make their money all right smart money
you can call it all right those guys
they can buy forever right
so the game is not uh very fair but this
is the game we are playing as retail
investors so careful guys uh i would
personally not buy too much between 280
and 270 even if i put a buy here a buy
here um
you know signal here
i put it small because i think that it's
important to prepare for the for the
case we go much lower so let me come
back to the scenarios one two three four
five maybe complete in this case we will
probably uh keep going higher get
rejected here all right a little bit
with jimmy coming here at 110 amc
probably at 13 or you know even maybe 14
and then we're gonna have a question
okay we're probably gonna be rejected
the first time
and then probably consolidate
and here either
we go lower or we break out okay so this
is gonna be what is gonna tell me if
we enter a longer correction
or if we are out of trouble at least for
a few weeks and can expect something
like that okay so i put a 50 50
probability to me i don't know what's
going to happen
but monitor what is going to happen here
and the bad scenario which i'm going to
play because i have stocks and i don't
want to you know and i have leverage so
i don't want to be stopped here
so for this reason i'm gonna increase my
short position and maybe try to make
some money on the way down
um and so this is the scenario i am
fearing
and
i mean i put 50 50 right because
i like to be bullish you know and to
give you bullish vibes guys
um
the truth is that maybe it's a 60 40
a little bit more bearish than bullish
and i'm gonna explain why and so this is
the sun in this scenario the one two
three four five is not a one two three
five is only one two three as you can
see
we are doing the false and we're gonna
have
a dramatic fear fifth happening all
right that could lose
25 percent and it's gonna happen quickly
guys it's gonna happen in a few days so
if it happens
so i'm personally prepared for the
scenario the fifth wave might go of
course only to 270 i don't know but
i'm careful about what i know about sea
waves sea waves are usually surprisingly
deep all right so that's why i would
first
think we're gonna find support here like
we did
but something is telling me this we are
not done here and if after testing 285
we go to 270 i mean you can see the
fifth wave would be very short right
so the probability we go lower would
actually be quite high at 270. so
careful maybe if you guys planned to buy
the dip here just don't go too heavy
not financial advice all right so if we
have this fifth wave then we'll probably
gonna have some kind of a rebound and at
least a sideways market
uh so yeah my target for the fifth wave
might be around 235 right so keep that
level in mind guys
i think that if the market comes here
buying here
is
not too risky even if it's gonna look
like guys this is the end of the world
everything is crashing i think this is
gonna be a right a good buying
opportunity as opposed to what is
happening right now i don't think right
now is such a good buying opportunity
but if i'm wrong it's totally fine
because here we're gonna have a breakout
and very likely a re-test around the
same level so this is gonna be a level
where we're gonna be able to buy here
stop-loss just below all right
so i'm still gonna find a way to
close my short position with a nice
profit because i took it here guys
and
keep my long positions on the other
stocks now let me finish this video with
the us 10 new yield and this is the
reason why
i believe
we might go lower
on the equity market i remind you guys
this
u.s tenure yield reflates uh i mean is
showing uh what investors
think of inflation
uh it reflects inflation and it also uh
makes
it
more challenging for equity to beat this
return and to be attractive for
investors all right so whenever this is
going up in an inflationary environment
equity is going down and we have a
breakout here as you can see on the
weekly time frame right i've been
talking about this breakout for the past
two weeks and unfortunately i was right
about that
the higher we're gonna go here the um
the more we're gonna crash and we had we
went to 320
all right so this is
historically high
okay lower than what we had in oct
october 18th but once again the breakout
occurred guys all right so
we don't really care about the recent
high we just had a rejection at the
first reason high for those who followed
my course you know this is the usual
you know scenario we break out we get
rejected at the first high
and then we re-test the breakout area
and we go higher so here i'm afraid that
this is only a re-test and as you can
see it has been quite perfect okay we
got rejected here we retested this level
282
all right and
and then now i'm what a fear is this all
right we keep consolidating and then we
go higher and if we do we're going to
have this fifth wave
on triple q all right it's
guaranteed
so
i'm as long as we are above this
breakout 280 roughly
i'm gonna be bearish on the equity
market at least i'm going to be very
careful uh with buying breakouts because
this to me
is the sign
of an unhealthy environment for
equity investment
simple
so i'm going to monitor that and once
again
uh
whenever we're gonna break out above
this bluetooth line i'm gonna start to
feel more bullish on mcgme on crypto
markets on
the other meme stocks all right so this
is what i'm personally paying attention
to that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to floor i see you guys
you